>> LOOK AT YOUR TV SCREEN RIGHT
NOW.
PAY CLOSE ATTENTION.
AUTHORITIES HAVE JUST RELEASED
THIS CLOSED CIRCUIT VIDEO FROM
INSIDE THE PRISON IN THE FINAL
MOMENTS BEFORE HE BROKE OUT.
SO HE PACED BACK AND FORTH.
YOU SAW THAT IN THE CELL.
AND THEN H GOES AROUND WHERE THE
TOILET IS.
WELL, HE DISAPPEARS INTO THE
TUNNEL.
THERE HE IS.
NOW HE'S GONE.
AT LEAST 49 PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
QUESTIONED IN CONNECTION WITH
THE ESCAPE.
THE MINISTER SAYS HE HAS FIXED
THE PRISON DIRECTOR -- OR FIRED
THE PRISON DIRECTOR AND OTHER
PRISON OFFICIALS.
THE DRAMATIC MOMENTS JUST BEFORE
OR JUST WHEN
>> LOOK AT YOUR TV SCREEN RIGHT
NOW.
PAY CLOSE ATTENTION.
AUTHORITIES HAVE JUST RELEASED
THIS CLOSED CIRCUIT VIDEO FROM
INSIDE THE PRISON IN THE FINAL
MOMENTS BEFORE HE BROKE OUT.
SO HE PACED BACK AND FORTH.
YOU SAW THAT IN THE CELL.